the meme of democracy and the
tenaciousness with which it has taken
hold all over the world is like the
Trump of judgment for the Dominator
culture it is the beginning of the
emergence of some kind of idea system
which is both integrated in its totality
and in its particulars it's a natural
symbiotic democracy of interlocking
Minds and intentionality in other words
it's a realization of humans of
humanity's intent on the planet and I
have said I have compared human
civilization to a coral reef well this
is going to be have to be carried even
further we are going to have to take
nature as a teacher in much the way that
the optimists of the 16th century talked
about it take nature as a teacher and
follow nature mimic nature always follow
her curves and her energy economies as
the only way to very slowly take this
thing apart without it going lethal
honest and the beginning of this is
unavoidably
the psychedelic experience because the
psychedelic experience is where you
means human nature outside the envelope
of cultural conditioning for the first
time I mean otherwise it's like never
having been naked or never having had
sex it's some kind of primary experience
which has been denied you if you have
never been outside the language shell
the culture shell the value shell and
actually experience the animal body and
mind in itself then you don't know the
ground of being so the story of human
institutions is the story of their
resistance to the human and search for
authenticity why this should be I don't
know but there is something perverse in
institutions they [ __ ] the free
exploration of the meaning of humanism
and the program of delivering a
reasonable and comfortable life to each
and every citizen in the body politic
can only be ultimately satisfied when
each and every atom of the body politic
has come into its birthright as a part
of divine being or
the hyperspatial entity behind reality
that sort of thing it's the promise of
religion but carried out through the
medium of technology under the direction
of the psychedelically eliminated
imagination just trying to break through
into the historical continuum and input
that template in place as opposed to
this lethal Dominator template that is
just taking us nowhere